foreign
Dove and Raven hi hello hey Dove and
Raven so
Dove your father
is how would you describe your yourself
Raven
are you you're not transgender are you
no I'm just a unique person I'm an
individual
and you've always been this way I've
always been a very unique individual yes
even since I was a kid my parents were
unique people so I had a an interesting
childhood
how did you grow up
well when the year I was born my parents
started a natural food store in
California it was you know the early 70s
they were um
you know trying to do something new at
the time
um so I was raised by them but they
split up when I was young
my dad stayed in the business uh the
health food eventually became religious
my mother stayed more on the wild end
and I lived with her a lot so we got to
travel around quite a bit I went to a
lot of different schools
and um saw a lot of crazy wild stuff uh
in the 70s as a kid people partying and
wildlife and stuff so that was uh kind
of how I grew up partially started doing
psychedelics very young yeah I grew up
you know experimenting in uh
psychedelics smoke marijuana and stuff
yeah and um
my uh
my father's side of the family were
conservative and I got a lot of balance
and good uh solid stuff from them and my
mom's side of the family too very loving
people very um
extraordinary personality so I got a lot
of good stuff from them but yeah there
was some rough things you know
experiences and stuff I guess that could
have made me
um helped add to the uh wildness of my
life I guess like what
um you know just growing up as a kid on
the streets a lot I was a skateboarder a
young skateboarder so I'd go out on my
skateboard and you know get wild and
explore the world like any kid yeah yeah
except I got maybe a little more freedom
than some kids and just the pattern of
my life since I was young was a little
yeah my parents may not
being more like hippie types I wasn't
you know immunized or circumcised or any
of those kind of things you know so I
was just a little more innately wild I
think anyways and then them being kind
of open-minded they gave me a little
more room maybe
um but yeah and then you had me how old
were you when you had me
29 when you were born
yeah
are you sure yeah okay Deb what do you
remember
um your childhood with your dad
my mom was very motherly my mom was like
23 when she had me and you were a few
years older and
they were very eccentric like definitely
hippies
um definitely hippies
and we moved around a little bit and
then this is where this is in central
California by the beach in a small town
okay yeah small town
and then
my dad transitioned a little bit during
the time of my parents splitting up
to a woman
and got Top surgery and changed her name
and changed their entire identity and
then my parents split up and me and my
mom and my brother moved to Northern
California
and
you were how old when this when your dad
transitioned it started when I was
pretty young I couldn't really even tell
you like an exact time because it was it
went in phases so
she would start cross-dressing and then
sometimes she would stop and be like
okay I'm gonna be
masculine again and then she'd start
cross-dressing again and when I was very
young I wouldn't
um I didn't really see it as that weird
because my mom wore skirts I wear skirts
my dad wearing skirts so it was just
like okay
people wear skirts
like I didn't think like men were not
supposed to wear skirts or dresses
but then when she
um like changed her name and stuff it
was very like strange and I remember
when you told me
that you were a female Soul trapped in a
man's body and that really freaked me
out because I was very young and I was
like I just I couldn't even comprehend
that
that didn't make any sense I was like
what like how could a soul be male or
female it didn't make any sense
so it was very strange
um yeah I don't know I I'm not sure if I
use those exact words I remember okay
maybe I did
um that phrase do you think it impacted
your childhood for sure that phrase
really I was like whoa like
female Soul male soul like what I I
probably did use that phrase I but I
probably was um influence it wasn't
probably something I originally thought
of on my own
um
when I first started going online when I
got access to the internet I got a lot
of information about
transgenderism and transsexual that I
had never encountered before
um it was a subject I'd been aware of
since I was young because of um you know
hearing about
cross-dressers and transvestites and how
you know they were weird or whatever but
I knew that I enjoyed
women's clothes or women I mean every I
liked everything about women I really
could identify with you know I cried
easy with movies all that stuff so to me
and I yeah I guess I did identify with a
female Spirit you know but not now I
don't see it any different than yeah a
male spirit I think Dove hit it when she
said how can a soul be male or female at
that time it wasn't very common like it
wasn't really talked about it was very
and it was confusing yes it was
separated like a man is like this a
woman is like this it was still like
that this is like 15 years ago you're
just ahead of your time maybe I was a
little ahead I was a little behind and a
little ahead but because now I see lots
of yeah no when I did it it was a it was
a scandal in the community let's say
yeah so it was very brave but but I um I
felt like it was the only way I could be
on like to me hiding the way I felt
um wasn't really an option and I had
since my early 20s been wearing unisex
or even female clothes you know I would
dress however I wanted to I might have a
beard but I'd still wear a skirt and
like a little Lacy thing on my head or
whatever because to me it was all part
of the magical my own unique expression
but when I became
with her mom and had to be the man and
then her kid then I got really into the
masculine being the man thing but um
but I was still able when I was home
with her mom and stuff to wear skirts
and she was cool with that she was used
to the Grateful Dead culture where men
wear skirts at these concerts and spin
around you know so your ex-wife was yeah
I don't know it would go that far yeah
she didn't know it would go that far and
I didn't either and it didn't have to
but it did you know things can go a lot
of different ways see how this goes was
that the cause of your divorce well yeah
this is what happened we were definitely
already we've been nine years together
and we'd had two kids and the second kid
was a lot of work and we were starting
to grow apart in our Valley we could
realizing our values were a little
different after nine years and there was
things I was really getting into being
vegetarian she was really wanting to eat
meat more it was that kind of thing
little things like that um and I things
about my lifestyle again were very um I
was total Outlaw kind of person you know
yeah I I made my money just totally
hustling I'd sell at the Swap made I do
construction on the side I'd sell weed I
sold Lots I was always a weed seller
weed grower whatever and so that kind of
work was hard for her I think to see
because when people oh what do you do
for a living I'd be like Oh I'm an
Outlaw I do all this stuff that was not
she was couldn't take pride in that and
the school that Dove ended up had a lot
of really wealthy families in it with
nice houses nice car they own this nice
big fancy and we were just struggling
you know I I was just a hustler we were
just trying to pay the rent basically I
had Ambitions and I'd had businesses and
stuff but they'd all kind of everything
would just go back to zero and I'd have
to start over and it didn't bother me at
all I was just doing my thing you know
um I was a collector and I'm kind of a
scholar I like to study and I'm a
musician so I was more you know I feel
the musical com the money will come
someday focus on the music so yeah her
mom wasn't comfortable with that so we
were already growing apart and um I had
quit expressing myself femininly in any
ways because her mom had started to
resent it you know because she wanted me
to be the man all of a sudden and she's
looking you know and that was
understandable so I tried to keep it
to a minimum I was like okay I don't
need that for myself but then I started
feeling
like maybe I did I think it's her mom
and I as we were as things really
started getting less comfortable between
us I started feeling ah there's
something missing here you know and I
and and it
to close off this part of myself my
being able to express myself in this way
it felt like it didn't feel right and
and to just hide it it felt dishonest
you know I felt like like
I this is something that I'm supposed to
be ashamed of which means I have to hide
it from everybody so I like have this
like dark secret about myself like I'm
this weird creepy perverted evil bad
person because you know I like to wear
clothes that only females are supposed
to wear and I'm a male ah you're
attracted to men or women or women I'm
attracted to women yeah when you're
dressed as a woman
yes anytime I'm always attracted to
women yes I love women um but both I can
be with men yes I have been with men
I've um as and we can get that might
come up more later but
um
but what happened was I got online one
day
and uh I read this stuff about
transsexual and I'd never heard this
information before and it said some
people are a female Soul trapped in a
male body just like David said and I
wasn't sure if that was exactly me but
it said you know and it said oh there's
also transgender and transsexual some
people are this and it Summits all the
way and but it was mainly pointing in a
certain direction and I was like huh and
I I I met with a counselor and I talked
to her and and uh she's like oh we can
start you on hormones anytime I'm like
hey I was just curious you know and um
and so
I went and I called her mom one day from
I had a little office in town and I
called her mom and I said uh hey I've
been reading this stuff about
transsexuals and transsexuality and
transgendered is I had no idea I said
but maybe this is maybe I'm kind of one
of these kind of people maybe this
explains why I like to dress and I'm so
you know I cry on the mood we watch a
movie and I'd be like sobbing and her
mom would be sitting there going what's
wrong with you you know and she just
thought I was really you know emotional
or whatever and and I am
um
but you know again if you let limit what
a man is allowed to express and what a
woman is allowed to express then it's
like oh I'm breaking the rules because
I'm expressing things that women are
supposed to express and not men
and I didn't like that I guess I don't
like being limited I'm looking for you
know I'm trying to make the most of life
every moment your dad is just a free
spirit though yep that's very eccentric
that's how I see her I don't know but
he's a great communicator he seems very
intelligent absolutely great just lovely
to be around yeah and that's much that's
much more important than having
a masculine masculine figure who who
sometimes is very brooding and won't
won't I agree because like I can tell
her him anything anything you know and
she's always supportive of me like it
doesn't matter what I do so yeah I'm
very grateful well there was some rough
years though so when I called her mom
and told her hey I saw this I'm
interested I thought maybe I'd get like
oh neat because she was always open and
helped me explore I mean she her mom
helped me do a lot of stuff it's an
extraordinary woman most extraordinary
woman I've ever known
when I called her up that day so that
all I got on the other phone was silence
I couldn't even get her to speak and so
I had to go home to talk to her and when
I got there she'd been crying
and I said what's wrong I was just and
she goes what do you mean what's wrong I
feel like you just called me up and told
me that you were dead or someone just
called me and told me that my man had
died
and I was like no no it's still me it's
not like that I'm just
that was it like she never recovered
from that shock
um
we tried there was a month or two where
she's like maybe I don't know but um we
were so close her mother and I and so
um affectionate in our ways that after
about a week or two of it not being that
way all of a sudden after nine years I
just couldn't handle it and I had a
little apartment in town where I worked
and I just
moved in there
and uh you know I I regretted it the day
I did it you know I I didn't think I was
leaving my family you know and I mean I
I they were still just a couple miles
away and my kids and I just but I just
couldn't be with their mom having her
all like detested you couldn't repress
this and and be the male figure I could
have maybe I was open to it I was just
like hey I just want to explore this
idea you know
um but to her it was just devastating I
like and um there were layers to it
there was layers but it was mainly it
really happened in this one like about a
month period there was the you know the
reveal the and then after about two
weeks me moving out
and then even after I moved out I would
come back and sleep there sometimes with
her and even and we were like oh maybe
we'll work this out and everything
um
but the other thing that happened is my
father had just died too
um so there was a um
you know a lot going on there for me too
I think my mother had died about 10
years before that and then my father
just died so I was going through a lot
of stuff you know personally around the
deaths of my parents my father and I had
a rough relationship he was a real man
man that you know uh pushed me to be
real tough and and try to do everything
righteously he's a very religious and
stuff so he had been a hippie and he
became a born-again Christian and then
went down another path you know as far
as that goes
um
uh extraordinary man really helped you
know a lot of the things that I love
about myself I I got to give a guy
credit for he was a great father
um despite the fact that he he wasn't in
my life a lot of the time but he was
quite a bit
um as much as he could be you know and
we always were in touch even when I
wasn't living with him so but uh
the um
yeah the influence of all that on me was
rough and and also I had been
burning the candle at both ends really
hard for years
um living the life I was because not
only did I want to be a great
husband and lover for her mom but I
wanted to be a great father which I
think I was I think I was the greatest
dad ever personally
but I was also very obsessed with I I
was a a book collector did a lot of
reading a lot of writing a musician
which you can imagine how much time and
energy that can take and then also
beside businesses
um you know gardening farming all that
kind of stuff just really burning the
candle at both ends I'd even had a Cafe
restaurant at one time that would have
me up from six in the morning till one
at night you know just working working
working so I probably
cause myself some mental
imbalances too just based on uh you know
stress and malnutrition and you know
just overdoing everything all at once
and just thinking I could handle
everything you know because I just felt
awesome doing everything I was doing I
did three seasons of uh Shakespeare
repertoire I did uh
different things like that so
um it was an awesome time but yeah it
ended drastically when the transgender
thing came out her mom is like are you
happier as as a ambiguous oh I'm happier
right now than I've ever been in my life
you know and I've mostly been a pretty
happy person except the breakup and the
transition were
incredibly dark like I'm I mean I just I
can't even hardly remember it it was so
dark it was like very feeling very
suicidal you know um very confused very
just confused to no end and I just and I
couldn't I had a really hard time
wrapping my head around the idea that
her mom did not want to be with me that
just I just could not get and it was
just the
I mean it's just such a blow to my ego
like I just couldn't recover I felt like
that was it you know I'd never be with a
woman again as long as I lived you know
because the ultimate woman had rejected
me so that was it that they were going
down a very traditional family path
so for change was really like oh that's
not what I was expecting it was hard for
all of us yeah
I don't um I think it's like
um there's good and bad out of it like I
really love how things are today but it
was definitely hard just I mean
different it was different well yeah
once that once it was clear that we were
breaking up and we'd gotten our own
places and stuff and she was still at
the school the way like she said I would
go to pick her up at school and now I'm
really experimenting with coming out so
instead of wearing a skirt at home I'm
wearing a little dress and heels and
stockings and a purse right out into
town you know because I had to that was
to me that was what I felt like I had to
do you know to come out yeah
um so yeah I go to her school and I
didn't think anything of it because
she'd always known that I wore dresses
and skirts at home what is it about
being a woman that that
is so appealing to you because you could
find a partner yeah who who is as sexy
as your enjoy whatever your fascination
is you could have a partner that's like
that
you mean uh find a woman that's
attracted to you instead of being an
attractive why be a woman you could just
hang out with that's how I feel today
but at the time I guess I didn't feel
that way because I was you know everyone
you want it on the fun well the ironic
thing is I did actually have a few
girlfriends after I broke up with her
mom and I was transitioning and they
didn't seem to care because
I guess I was even though I would wear a
dress some days some days I'd wear pants
you know they were girls pants but I
probably still look pretty masculine I
hadn't taken any hormones I still had
facial hair I still had muscles are you
taking hormones now no
I'm not but you have breasts it looks
like I do have breasts yes but not from
hormones these are uh what's the what's
the stuff called silicone silicone you
were she was on hormones for a while I
was on hormones for 10 years 10 years
almost almost 10 years yeah
so and it definitely changes you it's a
radical thing to do in what ways well it
it uh it makes your testosterone
you know kind of stop producing so it
goes way way down and it makes your
estrogen go way way up and so you feel
not like an average guy feels because an
average guy feels like testosterone high
estrogen low when so I guess I felt a
lot more like the average woman feels
more emotional
um I guess that's part of it yeah
there's a lot to it we could do a long
discussion on how hormones or how taking
estrogen affects a man I guess I never
took uh testosterone blockers
um and part of the reason for that was
um
so one thing you learn when you go down
this transsexual Rabbit Hole like if
you're online looking about is oh
transsexuals they have dysphoria and
they're not comfortable with their
genitals they feel like they got the
wrong thing down there and they don't
like it and they're uncomfortable I
never felt that way I was always very
comfortable with what I got down there
and enjoyed it and thought it was great
um even though going through the
literature and the transition I actually
tried on that thought and and like spent
like maybe a week or two kind of like I
detest might be I need a vagina you know
kind of thing but it wasn't really me it
didn't stick um maybe you're more of a
cross-dresser
yeah I guess you could say so I mean but
who knows what what is a cross-dresser
you know I don't know is this um
you have breasts so maybe you're more
than a cross-dresser maybe I'm more than
a crossover I don't know I remember what
if I what if I got the breasts removed
then what would I be does it really does
this does the outside stuff really
matter so it really doesn't matter to
you it seems yeah it's not that much I
mean perfectly lose the breast now just
because they get my way and they're big
and bouncy and you know and
um and maybe it makes girls
uncomfortable sometimes if they notice I
got boobs and I'm flirting with them I
don't know that that's true but
um but for a while you got me that you
wanted to look feminine to appeal to men
I remember that a few years ago
uh well yeah but that was based on one
thing in particular which is my work I
was working as an escort so um
I probably if I said I want to look
beautiful in the field it was definitely
only because of that money well okay for
money for work yes
um yeah it's a shame to make money that
way I think um but it was great for me
for many years I um you wouldn't want
your daughter doing it I would not want
my daughter doing it no and I I don't
really honestly I will probably not be
doing it I still to have clients
um
but I don't uh do it the way I used when
I first started doing it it was like a
real Desperado you know I mean I would
see anyone I would try you know I was
just trying to get I was trying to
survive I'd gotten down to where I was
even like I couldn't even drive my car I
was literally living on my bicycle out
of a backpack sleeping on the ground you
know so I got down to that low and I
thought
I'm gonna make I'm gonna do what I need
to do and I knew someone and I'd worked
as a strip when I was with her mom I'd
worked as a male stripper
um so it was already her mom knew that
and we were all you know in the game
with it but not very traditional male
and female route
traditional but open-minded so I'd
worked as a male stripper so it was easy
for me to go okay here's a way I can
make money without having to be
discriminated against or whatever you
know what I mean I was just able to I
had a friend in the business she or
she's a dominatrix she helped me get set
up with some advertisements and boom I
was on my way and I made great money so
um
and I was still able to have the freedom
that I so much love and at the time I
had started estrogen and so
um being sexual with men was actually I
did enjoy it it was pleasant I was it
was exciting it was new it was different
and it was yeah it was a grand Adventure
it was really awesome you know I would
have no regrets at all you know but of
course it's it I do have that um
the most the most depressing thing
wasn't the breakup with her mom and the
transitioning which was the darkest time
of my life but it was that for years
after that I was very alienated from my
daughter
and that kept me in a lot of turmoil at
all times because
um
I just I just felt like it was not fair
I felt like I was really trying to be
honest and do the best I could and I had
never wanted to leave living with her
and um and I had made so many attempts
to tell her mom hey let's get together
let's work this out even before I
started the hormones and and dressing so
much I said hey I don't know what this
means maybe I just need to dress a
little more feminine or something like
that you know but is this something you
had as a teenager yeah I first like
tried on like my sister's clothes or
something when I was like 13 or 14 and
that's how I discovered that it was
erotic you know um
but um I had had sexual stuff with other
children and older children since I was
very very very young you know and again
growing up with hippies I saw people so
sex in the sex world was I got very
active sexually as a young teenager with
other lady you know and so there was so
yeah that was a big part of my um my
life in general I guess you could say
very sexual person
um but the cross-dressing was only a
little thing when I was a young teenager
and then
um when I was in my 20s I started but
not like sexually like I'm gonna go
inside and while I look at a porn mag
look at my sister's panties or something
like that it was more like
um when you got into the church too in
between that time and I had also bit
gotten it I've had a time where I
studied and and did some really
dedicated uh
Christianity
um
so anyways in my 20s I just when I got
real free and I was you know Grateful
Dead and hippie stuff and living off the
land of your life what's that drugs have
been a part of your life other than the
the acid and we mainly just a marijuana
smoker you know and in my young teens I
tried just about everything probably
once
um and uh just you know saw some people
have horrible things I got real sick
myself once when I was like 13 and
almost died so I kind of learned my
lesson young so I've never been into
hard drugs since then I've experimented
a little bit in my teens I experiment a
lot with LSD and mushrooms and stuff
since then I've experimented a little
bit with some psilocybin
um you know had acid a couple of times
in my 20s but that's it I've now I'm
pretty much just it's really just this
is your personality oh okay I'm just
trying to figure out yeah no I'm an
unusual person I'm sure uh only in
California
yes yes yes you can do this in Kansas
lived in Hawaii for a few years as a kid
and got to see some real wild Freedom
over there
um
but um yeah so the cross-dressing again
in my 20s I just took it on as a style
you know because I've always had this
kind of fantasy image like I'm an
idealist and so I've always like grew up
with fantasy and you see these old
pictures of like Warriors or Knights or
whatever with their long hair flowing
back you know and they've got like some
waving Fabric or whatever that looks
like a dress you know so that was always
kind of my orientation I was like yeah
but that's that's a masculine right but
I wanted to look like that cool
masculine figure from fantasy who had
that you kind of do and all that
feminine stuff and I couldn't do it with
what they had down at you know Miller's
Outpost or whatever I had to call them
the thrift stores and find my own unique
you know
um style like that um and I guess you
know even my dad there's a story my dad
uh left from where he lit we lived up in
Santa Central California when he was a
kid or early 20s or something but he hit
the road with just his bamboo flute a
champion juicer and wearing this long
red coat that was his mother's
and he went like hitchhike to New York
like that or something that's
interesting yeah yeah he's in your blood
yeah yeah he used to wear a purple cape
for a while I heard back in the you know
this was the 60s
um
so yeah I had some wild blood in me to
begin with but yeah the cross dresses
just all fitted in I don't know I guess
I my personal idea is that everybody is
inherently a little bit bisexual whether
it would be expressed or not
um and I just really got tapped into all
that stuff but I'm so you know I was a
high testosterone very um
you know an artist and idealists so I
look at women with this I'd see the
beauty and I was just driven just oh you
know just such a such a profound draw
for me um towards that beautiful
femininity you know and so yeah to want
to express it myself you know I don't
know maybe I one time I was trying on
some feminine stuff and I looked in the
mirror and I was like wow you do look
you know as you kind of remind me of
those beautiful women in the magazines
I'm looking at you know or something
like that
um so yeah it was in there and it did
come out and in my like I said 20s I'm
just hanging out with other people I may
have a beard and but I'm still dressing
like that and no one thought anything of
it if I would try to mention it to
someone you know I feel kind of like a
girl or kind of like a man with a they
would always be like nah not you no way
you're such a man even if I was wearing
a skirt that's the kind of reaction I
would get and that was frustrating to me
because I wanted people to see me for
some reason it's more androgynous you
know how I felt even though I felt
extreme really masculine but it's like
I'm not only the most masculine person
you'll ever meet I'm also the most
feminine person you'll ever meet
and that just doesn't come across easy
people aren't ready to experience that
and even if they do they don't they
can't acknowledge it because it's
outside of their kin you know so
what happened after all these I find I
reached this point where I was such a
woman
that like I didn't have to try to pass
as a woman anymore I just go around and
people hi ma'am I miss and guys would be
like check her out and everything I was
like I was like I guess I really did it
you know but through my Journeys all
those Wild Adventures as I had working
as an escort and traveling all over to
see clients and stuff like that
I had some traumatic experiences and I
had my life and I watched my kids
growing up you know while I'm living
this life and my I have a son and he's
getting to be a man and I'm like
so it's just it's just started changing
and started feeling different and I just
started feeling more masculine too I
practiced a lot of hot yoga and stuff
like that and I've done a lot of therapy
over the last 10 years so I just really
started getting this feel of like none
of this matters
you know like what matters is just me
and my soul and my life and my happiness
like gender and identity and I was like
who cares like oh that's a healthy
attitude yeah you know and Dove seems to
have to have accepted it absolutely yeah
and she helped bring me back because
even though she was still resentful
towards me at the time around 16 or so
she started coming back into my life a
little you know and that really healed
me I mean it really healed the Deep she
loves her dad there was a deep hole in
me other
we've had such a great time since we've
gotten you know to be of close friends
again how was yours how did your son
handle it my son never batted an eye
um he was younger and he's a he's an
unusually empathet empathic sensitive
man young man he has just been so loving
and loyal to me through the whole even
when she was like because I saw the book
the buffer like yeah changed and he
didn't really see like as much of a
change it was just like his dad was
always he was he was like three when it
all started oh I said she was eight it's
amazing what a child will just get used
to it yeah and he got used to it it is
what's normal he just loved me the way I
was and I loved him and we stayed so and
it was really
important to me because she had kind of
distanced herself for me so he was you
know I I just uh had him and and so that
was really really helpful for me but as
they both got older and I started
getting close to her again it really
coincided with me just
it was like I started growing out of the
whole transsexual thing or something you
know
um and I suddenly was concerned about
the estrogen and in fact it was the
effect it would have on my health and my
body long term and I said I got it for a
few years I've been I had cut way down
they'd start me on a fairly high dose
and I'd cut down and then a few years
later I cut down even more so I was on a
low estrogen dose but it was enough to
keep me very feminine and passing and
attractive to men but um
uh I just knew it was I had to go I
wanted so about three years ago I just
quit it and um
since then I've just been going back
feeling more and more masculine
um sometimes the whole thing seems like
a dream I'm like how did I get these
boobs like this is really weird what
what happened where was I for the last
10 years
um because how has this impacted your
your interactions with with
with men in your life when I was younger
I didn't really trust men or like you
know
but now that I'm older like I don't know
I really see everybody like just as they
are I don't really judge people when I
first meet them I just see the best in
people for the most part even if I can
see that they're not like having the
most pure intentions I just like see
everyone as they are I guess so I kind
of just I have a positive outlook on
humanity and now there are guys your age
probably that are
kind of ambiguous in there yeah I've met
plenty plenty yeah and they're all
unique it's just different like whatever
age you're at however you want to
express yourself like whenever you want
to transition
like it's up to you but like yeah if
you're gonna
get a surgery that kind of sterilizes
you like maybe think about it for a long
time I'm glad I never did any of that
stuff yeah
yeah well and that I mentioned I never
took the testosterone blockers so I had
started to work as an escort
right about the time I started taking
the hormones it kind of coincided and uh
uh the hormones definitely helped me a
lot but
um
because I'd started working in that way
the doctor asked me she said do you want
to take these hormone blockers he says
because do you want to stay functional
and um
and in my work obviously uh that was a
big draw was that I was a functional
person so she's like oh well you don't
have to take them you can and then
you'll you can get all the benefits of
estrogen and yet still be functional you
know so
um
so I'm glad I made that choice because I
was once I quit the estrogen everything
came back just the way it had always
been I mean it hadn't really changed
that much anyways um so now yeah I'm
a girl at my yoga studio asked me the
other day she said what's your pronouns
do you like he or she and I said I
really don't care it really doesn't
matter to me
but if it makes a difference if I
thought it would make a difference to a
woman that I wanted to maybe attract
then I would probably choose whatever I
thought she would want to hear so if
that means being a man I would say I'm a
man you know but I don't want to um
I don't feel like I need to try to be
like I'm a man not a woman you know that
whole thing as a matter of fact what I
feel like is I actually accomplished my
my dream of being a drudge in it like of
being kind of both because my whole
thing is how beautiful that a human
being could be both and express it all
without having to have all the crap
that goes you know the social crap that
goes with it
um these uh let's call them pendulums of
human you know um Endeavor to try to
create a system of things that
um perpetuates itself whatever that is
uh like a transsexual or transsexualism
or transgender or you know as soon as
anything becomes an industry
it's dead it's too corrupt and and the
people of her generation and younger
they know better now that's why they're
like it doesn't matter you could be
lgbtq r s t u v y w x y z it doesn't
matter you know what matters is the
stuff that matters the stuff that's
underneath the superficial layers you
know not the gender but
things like love and character right and
uh values and um yeah you know those are
those are the things that really matter
um that's a great lesson yeah it's been
a good lesson all right well Dove and
Raven thank you so much for
letting us know what your what your
lives are like and how this
how this can even happen I think it's
fascinating this is one example yes
all right thank you so much thank you
very good